[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein ganz klassisches Rezept.
Wir werden Marillenknödel machen,
also Aprikosenknödel.
Ich musste mich gerade noch mal vergewissern,
was der Unterschied zwischen Aprikosen und Marillen ist.
Der Unterschied ist, dass die Österreicher einfach
Marille sagen
und die Deutschen Aprikose.
Und dann gibt es ja noch die Mirabelle.
Und das ist wieder was anderes.
Das sind eher so kleine Pflaumen.
Und ich habe in meinem...
Mein Obstbaum ist Aprimira,
Aprikose-Mirabelle-Mischung.
Ich bin völlig durcheinander.
Jedenfalls werden wir dieses leckere Dessert zubereiten.
In Österreich habe ich es schon gegessen.
Man kann das Ganze auch
mit Erdbeeren zum Beispiel machen zur Erdbeerzeit
oder auch anderes Obst verwenden.
Heute gibt es die aber mit Aprikosen.
Und traditionell werden dann die Aprikosen
entsteint und dann kommt da ein Würfelzucker rein.
Ich mache aber keinen Würfelzucker rein,
sondern Marzipanrohmasse.
Dafür verwende ich also für die Füllung
etwas Marzipanrohmasse.
Hier habe ich Aprikosen.
Dann brauche ich für den Teig
zwei Eier,
500 Gramm Quark oder Topfen,
150 Gramm weiche Butter,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
400 Gramm Mehl
und eine Prise Salz.
Und später dann zum Drinwälzen
noch mal etwas Butter,
Semmelbrösel
und etwas Zimt.
Bei der Marzipanrohmasse könnt ihr entscheiden,
ob ihr die pur nehmt
oder ob ihr geschmackliche Variationen nehmt.
Ich habe hier einmal
Heavenly Grace.
Dann gibt es die Geschmacksrichtung Amaretto,
Sanddorn, Orange.
Da dürft ihr einfach selbst entscheiden.
Das ist auch das Erste, was ich machen werde.
Das heißt, die Aprikose aufschlitzen.
Ich mache die auch nicht
– also ich halbiere sie nicht,
sondern ich mache nur einen Schlitz rein,
nehme den Kern raus
und da kann ich dann gleich Marzipan reingeben.
Und wenn ihr kein Marzipan mögt,
macht es halt ganz klassisch
und steckt einen Würfelzucker rein.
So kommt einfach noch ein bisschen Süße mit rein.
Und vor allem habe ich ja im Teig keinen Zucker.
Also darf die Aprikose ruhig ein bisschen Süße haben.
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt Heavenly Grace,
Edelmarzipan mit Mandelstückchen.
Und jetzt nehme ich das einfach so
ungefähr in Kerngröße.
Okay, ein bisschen größer.
Egal.
Ich kriege das hier rein.
Oder?
Nee, ich muss schon Kerngröße.
Sonst geht es nicht rein.
Das, was rausgeht, muss dann halt danach wieder rein.
So.
Und dann einfach ein bisschen zusammendrücken.
Durch die Marzipanrohmasse hält es auch schön zusammen.
[Musik]
Also der Josh, der würde definitiv
– um es in Joshs Worten auszudrücken:
"Safe würde ich da Nougat reinmachen."
Komm, es war schon deine Wortwahl.
>> JOSH: Vielleicht würde ich es so sagen. Ja.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht.
Vielleicht.
Safe würdest du es so sagen.
>> JOSH: Ja, ja. Es wäre halt schon...
>> SALLY: Schon nice?
Ach, du.
Mmh, mit Nougat!
Aber Marzipan ist halt auch mein Favorit.
Das ist schon...
Ich bin da immer so im Dilemma: Marzipan oder Nougat?
Marzipan oder Nougat?
Und dann denke ich mir so: "Boah, beides!
Einfach beides."
Neulich schrieb eine Zuschauerin,
die uns auch schon lange folgt und kommentiert,
schrieb sie, sie kann kein Nougat mehr sehen.
Und dann habe ich geantwortet:
"Wenn du unseren Nougat probierst, dann
puh..."
Ja.
Die heißt Nal123.
Hm.
Kommentiert immer viel.
Vielen Dank!
Sie schaut sich bestimmt auch dieses Video an
und dann sieht sie, dass ich sie gegrüßt habe.
[Musik]
Für den Teig gebe ich jetzt die Eier in eine Rührschüssel.
Das ist so ein ganz schneller Quark-Butter-Teig.
Und da muss man auch großartig nichts beachten,
außer,
dass einfach die Butter weich ist,
damit sie sich wirklich schön verbindet.
So. In Deutschland heißt es Quark,
in Österreich Topfen.
Die weiche Butter dazu.
[Musik]
Ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt.
Und dann kommt jetzt hier noch das Mehl dazu mit dem Salz.
Und der Teig wird einfach kurz verbunden,
bis er schön homogen ist.
[Musik]
Das war es schon.
Das war es schon, Josh.
Ich hole jetzt direkt mal den Topf
und ein Schneidebrett
– nee, eine Backmatte.
>> JOSH: Hast du da etwa gerade gekleckert?
>> SALLY: Ich bin
– das war wie im Film.
Ich kam mit meinem Arm auf diesen Löffel
und dann hat es hier alles rumgeschossen.
Ups!
O Mann!
Warum?!
Aber weiß du was, Josh?
Das war schon so ein Boss Move.
>> JOSH: Hat sie gerade einen Staubsauger
aus der Schublade geholt?
>> SALLY: Hat sie gerade den Staubsauger da rausgeholt?
Ja, das hat sie.
[Musik]
Also das Wasser mache ich jetzt schon einmal an.
Dann ein bisschen Mehl.
Vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen Mehl hier drauf.
[Musik]
Jetzt eine Rolle formen.
Dann geht das Einteilen nämlich einfacher.
[Musik]
Oh! Was auch richtig gut kommt, denke ich, im Teig,
ist ein bisschen Zitronenabrieb.
So ein bisschen da. Ja.
Also ich habe jetzt mal
die ganze Backmattenbreite ausgenutzt.
Das sind 40 cm.
Ich habe 10 Aprikosen.
Also mache ich immer
nach 4 cm einen Cut.
Also schön die Viererreihe.
4, 8, 12, 16, 20,
Weißt du, Josh, das ist nicht nur einfach kochen hier.
Das ist auch ein bisschen Mathe,
manchmal Physik,
manchmal Chemie.
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch hier
so ein bisschen Teig,
also eine Portion Teig,
öffnet sie in der Handfläche zu einem Kreis,
legt die gefüllte Aprikose hinein
oder das andere Obst, was ihr habt,
und verschließt es.
Schön gleichmäßig.
Und wenn es ein bisschen klebt,
ein bisschen Mehl an die Hände nehmen
und dann verschließen wie so eine Buchtel.
Ta-daa!
Und wenn ihr jetzt kleineres Obst habt,
kann es natürlich sein,
dass ihr einfach ein bisschen weniger Teig nehmt
und eben mehrere Portionen daraus bekommt.
Aber größer als eine Aprikose wäre schon ziemlich groß.
>> JOSH: Oder eine Melone.
>> SALLY: Eine Melone!
Dann nehmt ihr die komplette Portion.
Bitte nicht! Bitte macht es nicht!
O mein Gott!
Melonenknödel!
Wow!
Guckt mal, wie schön.
Ta-daa!
Wie so ein Schneeball.
[Musik]
Also ich habe ja jetzt hier schon parallel Wasser aufgesetzt,
ohne Salz, ohne alles,
einfach zum Kochen gebracht.
Das stelle ich jetzt ein bisschen runter.
Denn kochen soll es jetzt nicht, sondern nur sieden.
Und was ich hier noch machen werde, ist:
Ich habe hier schon eine beschichtete Pfanne.
Da kommt die restliche Butter rein.
Die, die nicht in den Teig gehörte.
Die kann man auch schon mal zerlassen.
Denn darin wird es später dann noch mal so geschwenkt
mit den Butter-
– mit den Brotkrümelchen.
Und jetzt hier das Wasser runterstellen.
Es ist halt echt auch ein schnelles Rezept.
Also, wenn ihr das mal so als Nachtisch machen wollt,
schon gut.
Und ich gucke jetzt, dass ich es vorher
noch mal schön rund rolle.
Und dann wirklich nur sieden lassen.
Und die brauchen dann,
ha, so zehn, zwölf Minuten.
Die Aprikosen sollen ja auch schön weich werden.
[Musik]
Und ich gebe jetzt hier aber nur fünf gleichzeitig ins Wasser,
weil es ansonsten echt zu viel wird.
Ihr könnt ja auch mit zwei Töpfen arbeiten.
Und jetzt wirklich so zehn, zwölf
bis fünfzehn Minuten sieden lassen.
Und die schwimmen dann auch gleich oben,
wenn sie fertig sind.
In der Zwischenzeit schmilzt hier schon die Butter.
Und ich kann auch hier gleich
die Semmelbrösel mit dem Zimt dazu geben
und einfach schon mal vorbereiten
und hier drinnen lassen.
Also so ein bisschen anrösten.
Und nach dem Sieden kommen die nämlich direkt hier rein.
[Musik]
Und in der Zwischenzeit einfach weiter rollen.
Guckt mal. Der eine, der schwimmt jetzt schon oben.
Der ist jetzt gar.
Und die anderen, die kommen jetzt gleich nach oben,
alle nacheinander.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind die Marillenknödel fertig!
Und dann hebt ihr sie heraus.
Dann kommen sie in die Mischung.
Wow, wow, wow!
Oh, ist das Leckerschmecker!
Und dann auf einen Teller.
Und da das Rezept so superschnell geht,
probieren wir es auch direkt.
Sarah, Josh,
seid ihr bereit?
>> SARAH: Ja, wir sind bereit.
>> SALLY: Oh, nehmt ihr Besteck mit?
>> JOSH: Ja, ich hole Besteck.
>> SALLY: Und eigentlich passt da
– was passt gut dazu, Sarah?
>> SARAH: Vanillesoße?
>> SALLY: Oh ja!
>> SARAH: Oder
Marmelade?
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> SARAH: Alles!
>> JOSH: Nougat.
>> SALLY: Auch gut.
>> SARAH: Oh, Nougat!
>> SALLY: Woah!
Hättest du vielleicht noch einen Teller für mich?
>> SARAH: Ja, klar.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich bin gerade so: "Hui!"
Und ihr seht auch, die Semmelbrösel,
die sind jetzt schön gebräunt.
Falsche Kamera.
Und ihr seht jetzt auch, die Semmelbrösel,
die sind schön gebräunt.
Ja, wir mussten jetzt hier mit Stativ,
weil der Josh jetzt hier probiert.
>> SARAH: Der ist für das Foto.
>> JOSH: Ich komme. Guck mal, ich passe gar nicht ins Bild.
>> SALLY: Der ist für das Foto?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Dann brauchen wir noch einen Teller.
>> SARAH: Wow!
>> JOSH: Okay, mache ich.
>> SALLY: Und guckt einmal hier,
einfach so ein bisschen schwenken.
Und...
>> SARAH: Das ist so schön!
>> SALLY: Oh, danke!
>> JOSH: Und zack.
Oh, wow!
Das haftet ja voll gut.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Weil die so
so nass praktisch hier reinkommen.
Und dann einfach so schwenken, schwenken.
>> SARAH: Weil du so professionell
den Knödel in der Pfanne schwenkst.
Oder ein Wunder.
>> JOSH: So ist es. Das ist komplett verrückt!
>> SALLY: Okay. Ich mache jetzt alle hier rein.
Und wir können vielleicht einen probieren
und dann nehmen wir die anderen für die Fotos, oder?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Machen wir das so?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, oder?
>> SARAH: Also machen wir hier die für die Fotos drauf
und den probieren wir.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Und warum haben wir dann einen dritten?
>> SALLY: Und dann kam der Josh mit der Idee,
– o mein Gott, und Sarah, jetzt wirst du auch ausflippen –
dass wir die Knödel auch mal frittieren müssen.
>> JOSH: So was...
>> SARAH: Am Frittier-Friday?
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> JOSH: So was von! Die werden frittiert!
>> SARAH: Fritty Friday?
>> SALLY: Wir wollen hier mal einen Fritty Friday machen
und wollen einfach frittieren.
Das heißt: Soll ich die jetzt noch backen?
>> JOSH: Man könnte sie schon mal.
>> SALLY: Aber wir haben heute keine Zeit mehr.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wir machen es so:
Wir probieren die jetzt, beenden das Video
und, wenn wir morgen früh Zeit haben,
machen wir das Gleiche noch mal und frittieren die noch.
Und dann hängen wir es mit an das Video dran.
>> JOSH: Oh ja!
>> SALLY: Oder?
>> JOSH: Ja, das probieren wir aus.
>> SARAH: Auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Deal?
>> JOSH: Und können wir dann auch Nougat reinmachen
und dann frittieren?
>> SALLY: Okay. Weißt du was?
Wir machen ein eigenständiges Video.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Jetzt nimmt es Ausmaße an.
>> SARAH: Nougat und frittiert?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SARAH: Ich flippe aus.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
Okay.
Also jetzt habt ihr hier so einen Knödel.
>> JOSH: Bitte schön.
>> SALLY: Und dann nehmt ihr einfach
– also Vanillesoße, perfekt dazu.
Marmelade, perfekt.
In der Mitte ist Marzipan.
>> JOSH: Ui!
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Oh, sind die schön!
O mein Gott!
>> JOSH: Du kannst es in die Kamera halten hier.
>> SARAH: Das wird ein schönes Foto.
>> SALLY: Hier, guckt einmal.
O mein Gott! Wie schön!
Jetzt hängt nur mein Marzipan am Messer.
Aber das tun wir hier gleich wieder rein, gell?
>> SARAH: Wir essen es ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, wir essen es ja jetzt gleich.
Achtung. Ich schneide das noch mal so.
>> SARAH: Vielen Dank.
>> SALLY: Und dann so.
Oh, wow!
Also ich muss ganz unanständig einfach aus der Hand essen.
>> SARAH: Ja, ich glaube, das geht mit der Gabel gar nicht.
>> JOSH: Okay. Komm.
>> SARAH: Wenn du aus der Hand isst, machen wir das auch.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Da Soße drüber und dann boah!
>> JOSH: Das bröselt so ein bisschen.
Ja, wir machen danach sauber.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
Boah!
>> SALLY: Oh, ich habe was vergessen!
>> SARAH & JOSH: Hm?
>> SARAH: Was?
>> SALLY: Süßer Schnee!
>> SARAH: Egal, es schmeckt so lecker!
Ich brauche auch nicht.
Es schmeckt so lecker!
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Denn es ist gar nicht süß.
Im Teig ist ja kein Zucker.
Nur im Marzipan ist ein bisschen Zucker,
aber ich habe einen ganz tollen Marzipan mit viel Mandelanteil.
Das heißt, die Süße kommt dann echt
durch den süßen Schnee.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Oder durch die Soße.
>> JOSH: Ich wollte jetzt gerade sagen:
"Das schmeckt ja wie..."
Aber mir fällt nichts ein, wie es schmeckt.
Das schmeckt einfach megalecker!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ich finde, dass
die Marille
– Marille? Aprikose?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Was ist der Unterschied?
>> SALLY: Marille sagen Österreicher und Bayern
und in Deutschland sagt man Aprikose.
>> SARAH: Okay.
Die Aprikose bringt, finde ich, auch eine Süße rein.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Das ist richtig lecker.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Megagut!
>> SARAH: Und das Warme!
>> SALLY: Der warme Marzipan.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
>> SARAH: Esst es, wenn es noch warm ist!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SARAH: Boah!
>> JOSH: Wenn man also jetzt noch Nougat reinmacht
und es dann frittiert...
>> SALLY: Oh, wow!
>> SARAH: Und der Nougat so schmilzt.
>> SALLY: Oh, wisst ihr, was auch gut dazu schmeckt?
>> JOSH: Hui!
>> SALLY: Vanilleeis.
>> JOSH: Oh!
Dann noch so warm.
>> SALLY: Vanilleeis und dann
>> SARAH: Wo ist unser Vanilleeis?
>> SALLY: so einen Knödel.
Ich habe nur noch Brownie-Eis im Kühlschrank.
>> JOSH: Nougat!
Wir sind wieder – wir sind beim Nougat!
>> SARAH: Wo ist unser...
>> SALLY: Oh, lecker!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> JOSH: Richtig gut!
>> SARAH: Ich brauche noch ein Stück.
>> SALLY: Findet ihr das Verhältnis Teig zu Füllung gut?
Man kann es auch dünner machen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SARAH: Also ich finde tatsächlich
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde...
>> SARAH: den Teig dünner ein bisschen besser.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Weil ich hatte jetzt am Schluss noch zu viel Teig
>> SARAH: über.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube...
>> SARAH: Wenn man da dann Nougat drauf macht...
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, aus der Menge
– gut, wenn man es mit Beilage isst, so mit Soße,
finde ich es perfekt.
>> SARAH: Hm. Hm.
>> SALLY: Wenn man sie so solo lässt,
finde ich, kann man aus der Menge 12 bis 14 Stück machen.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann hat man einfach einen dünneren Teig.
Oh, wow!
Lecker!
>> SARAH: Das war ein gutes...
>> SALLY: Das war ein gutes
>> SALLY & SARAH: Frühstück.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also schreibt mir doch mal gerne,
ob ihr schon mal Marillenknödel/Aprikosenknödel
gegessen habt,
was eure Lieblingsfüllung ist
– okay, wenn es Marillenknödel sind, sind es Marillen.
Wenn ihr süße Knödel,
>> SARAH: Aprikosen.
>> SALLY: so Quarkknödel.
Und schreibt, ob ihr es mal ausprobieren werdet.
Und ich sage euch, das schmeckt echt hammerlecker.
O mein Gott!
Und die frittierte Version...
Woah, ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht hängen wir sie noch hinten dran.
>> SARAH: Auf jeden Fall!
>> SALLY: Wir entscheiden morgen früh.
>> SARAH: Wenn wir morgen früh Zeit haben.
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Und einen guten Appetit!
Ich freue mich so richtig, da noch mal eine davon zu essen.
>> SARAH: Erst fotografiere ich es.
>> SALLY: Und dann sehen wir uns nächstes Mal wieder.
Tschüss!
>> JOSH: He!
>> SARAH: Nein!
>> JOSH: Was?
>> SARAH: Ich fotografiere es noch.
[Musik]